une autre analyse sur ce qui est à
surveiller au lendemain de l'élection
fédérale
aniche alloué professeur à l'université
de sherbrooke et directrice du climato
scop marshall ou bonsoir bonsoir
est-ce que l'enjeu environnemental a été
important durant cette campagne quelle
interprétation vous faites des résultats
d'hier à ce sujet d'ailleurs les
résultats je pense qu'ils nous montrent
une hausse importante des préoccupations
populaires à l'égard des questions
environnementales que ce soit par la
hausse du vote pour le parti vert le
nombre de sièges obtenus par le parti
vert mais aussi la place qu'occupe et
l'environnement dans les plateformes
politiques des trois autres grands
partis politiques que sont le npd le
bloc québécois et le parti libéral nous
montre que ç'a vraiment été une priorité
et on voit aussi qu'avec la balance du
pouvoir qui s'annonce bien
l'environnement risque d'être prioriser
au sein du gouvernement trudeau
quelle analyse est ce que vous faites
proprement quelques dossiers comme la
tarification du carbone notamment et
trans mountain france manton quelle
analyse ou fait de la suite des choses à
prévoir pour le pipeline trans pantone
ça reste des tas dossier extrêmement
litigieux pour le gouvernement trudeau
c'est un peu comme une patate chaude
dans les résultats qui ont qui sont
sortis arts nous montre un homme est
complètement bloquée donc pour les
libéraux ce que ça nous montre c'est que
le rachat de l'oléoduc semble ne pas
satisfaire l'électorat de l'alberta de
la saskatchewan notamment qui aurait
peut-être souhaité plus ou différent sur
la question de l'oléoduc
alors que du côté de l'est québec
ontario et les provinces maritimes cet
enjeu les experts extrêmement difficile
je pense que c'est un enjeu qui ne passe
pas dans une frange de plus en plus
importante de l'électorat donc sur
l'enjeu eux mêmes à savoir si le
gouvernement veut continuer à investir
ça devient très difficile parce que les
conservateurs d'un côté ne veulent pas
que l'argent du public serve à l'oléoduc
en même temps c'est un outil de
développement d'exploitation des sables
bitumineux alors que pour les groupes
environnementaux les la population qui
de plus en plus sensibles aux questions
environnementales
c'est une incohérence évidente par
rapport à la lutte aux changements
climatiques donc je pense que la manière
de piloter ce dossier là va être
extrêmement difficile du côté ni par la
libérale vous avez raison en même temps
on imagine que les conservateurs et un
an
faveur du développement du pétrole
appuierez les libéraux sur cet enjeu on
pourrait penser ça mais le point très
difficile c'est que si les libéraux
souhaitent maintenir au pouvoir par la
suite bien vont ils vont se nuire ils
vont nuire à une partie de l'électorat
qui ne voudraient plus voter pour les
libéraux
si jamais il ne remplit pas ses
promesses de lutte contre les
changements climatiques
et là il pourrait perdre encore plus de
voix au québec en ontario et dans les
provinces maritimes
donc c'est un jeu extrêmement difficile
chaque pillon qui va être bougé sur cet
échiquier leur risque de nuire aux
libéraux
donc il sait vraiment pas gagné ouais la
tarification du carbone maintenant on
comprend qu'elle est là pour rester est
ce que vous êtes d'accord qu'elle est
vraiment là pour rester à partir de
maintenant elle est là pour rester tenté
aussi longtemps que la cour suprême
statue sur la question ça devrait venir
dans les prochains mois qu'on devrait
savoir s'il va entériner les décisions
des juges des cours antérieurs qui ont
qui ont aussi reconnu la pertinence
d'ottawa en ce qui a trait à la
tarification carbone donc advenant le
cas que la cour suprême reconnaît donc
la prescience du fédéral est la
possibilité pour le fédéral de mettre en
place une tarification carbone je pense
qu'elle va rester et le les libéraux
vont faire face à un choix difficile
c'est-à-dire annoncé aux canadiens qui
va aussi y avoir des hausses par la
suite dans les années subséquentes parce
que là la tarification carbone est
appelée à augmenter de 10 $ par année
jusqu'en 2022 mais on s'attend aussi à
ce que cette tarification la augmente
annuellement par la suite également si
on veut s'approcher de cette ces
bleus-là qui était prévu par le
gouvernement libéral d'une réduction de
30 % sous les niveaux de 2005 pour 2030
donc c'est non pas longtemps on doit
mettre en place donc énormément
d'infrastructures et bien sûr un des
piliers de la lutte aux changements
climatiques demeure la tarification
carbone donc rien n'est joué encore
parce qu'on entend le jugement la cour
suprême mais reste qu on est sur la
bonne voie on pense que c'est que la
tarification vaut donc que perdurer dans
le temps et les libéraux n'ont rien dit
de cela d'ailleurs en au delà de 50
dollars les conservateurs ont posé
beaucoup de questions pour savoir à
combien on ira après cinq ans jamais les
libéraux n'ont voulu répondre je présume
qu'ils devront l'expliqué maintenant
d'autant que le directeur parlementaire
du budget
disait pour atteindre les objectifs de
paris faut aller au delà de 100 dollars
la tonne de carbone
oui et on imagine bien que par la suite
probablement que les augmentations
seront à la hauteur peut-être de 10 15
dollars la tonnes par année pour
justement atteindre cette cible à 2030
beaucoup reste à faire le canada doit
vraiment réformer un peu son économie
celle veut entrer dans une dans une
économie verte et ça va parce et bien
sûr par la tarification carbone et on
doit s'attendre comme canadien est ce
que cette hausse le soin soit récurrente
est ce qu est ce qu il faut s'attendre à
ce que l'environnement prennent plus de
place je pense à l'élection de steven
guilbeault bien sûr ancien de greenpeace
éditeur qui a été élu dans laurier
sainte marie à montréal qui pourrait
peut-être ministre de l'environnement
oui je pense que le choix d'avoir fait
la d'avoir obtenu les d'abord la
candidature de stéphane guilbaud mais
son élection à sa très forte majorité
nous montre qu'il ya une population si
importante qui est derrière cette
candidature et je pense que le
gouvernement libéral en choisissant la
candidature de steven guilbault
souhaitait vraiment en faire une
priorité parce que c'est un candidat
bien sûr que 25 ans d'expérience dans le
milieu environnemental c'est quelqu'un
qui s'est dévoué à la cause en
travaillant autant avec les partis les
différents partis politiques au sein du
gouvernement que dans les entreprises
né via son on s'attend aussi à ce qu'ils
fassent ce même travail là de
l'intérieur et bien sûr qu'ils
influencent la politique canadienne et
peut-être qu'elle soit plus rassembleuse
pour l'ensemble des futurs conseil des
ministres pour vraiment convaincre
on amorce une tangente vers une économie
verte anny chaillot merci beaucoup pour
cette analyse ce soir merci beaucoup à
voir